اهلا بكم في جوله الحصاد الاخباريه وفي
العناوين
وسط اشتباكات في الخرطوم وام درمان
وكوردوفان طرفاه القتال يعلنان تمديد
الهدنه رغم تواصل خلقها الجيش يقول ان
موافقته على التمديد جاءت استجابه لمساع
سعوديه وامريكيه والدعم السريع يقول ان
التمديد ياتي بعد نداءات دوليه واقليميه
ومحليه
الامم المتحده تعلن ارسال منسق الشؤون
الانسانيه فورا الى المنطقه في ضوء الازمه
المتدهوره في السودان وتحذر من تداعيات
طويله الامد على البلد والمنطقه لما اسمته
تسارعا غير مسبوق لوتيره الاحداث ومن داخل
افريقيا وزير خارجيه جيبوتي يقول ان
الصراع ستكون له عواقب وخيمه على القاره
كلها
وسط تدمر من شح الذخيره لدى مقاتليه
وتهديد بسحبهم من جبهات القتال رئيس
فاجنبي يحذر من هجوم اوكراني المضاد قد
يشكل ماساه لروسيا ومع تصدر باخ معتل مشهد
الميداني في اوكرانيا كيف تقول انها تسيطر
على طريق امداد حيوي وموسكو تعلن السيطره
على اربع مناطق في غرب المدينه
[موسيقى]
اعلن الجيش السوداني موافقته على هدنه
لمده ثلاثه ايام تبدا من انتهاء الهدنه
المعلنه وذلك بعد وساطه امريكيه سعوديه
وقال الجيش السوداني في بيان انه يامل ان
يلتزم من وصفهم بالمتمردين بمتطلبات تنفيذ
الهدنه مع جاهزيته التامه للتعامل مع اي
خروقات حسب قوله واضاف بيان الجيش
السوداني ان المتمردين لجاوا الى سياسه
الارض المحروقه بسبب فشل مخططاتهم في
الاستيلاء على السلطه بالقوه كما قال
الجيش السوداني رصده مستمر لتحركات العدو
واستدعائه لقوات مندحره من خارج العاصمه
لتعزيز موقفه العملياتي
واضاف الجيش السوداني انه جاهز لصد وتدمير
اي محاوله للهجوم على اي موقع في العاصمه
ينوي العدو مهاجمته غدا حسب قوله
وكانت قوات الدعم السريع قد اعلنت في بيان
موافقتها على تمديد الهدنه الانسانيه 72
ساعه اعتبارا من منتصف هذه الليله استجابه
لما وصفتها بنداءات دوليه واقليميه ومحليه
بهدف فتح الممرات الانسانيه وتسهيل حركه
المواطنين والمقيمين وتمكينهم من قضاء
احتياجاتهم والوصول الى مناطق امنه
التطورات الميدانيه التي شهدها اليوم
السادس عشر من المواجهات في السودان
نتابعها في هذا التقرير للزميل عبد القادر
عراضه
في يوم هو السادس عشر من الاشتباكات في
السودان وبعد ان كانت ام درمان المدينه
الثانيه ضمن مدن الخرطوم الكبرى مسرحا
لمواجهات تحديدا في منطقه الصالحه وهي
بالاصل تضم معسكره للدعم السريع شهدت
المدينه قصفا من الطيران الحربي للجيش
السوداني استهدف ارتكازات لدعم السريع
بابو سعد الجنوبي المدينه وايضا تعزيزات
له عند مدخل المدينه الواقعه غربي الخرطوم
شمال الخرطوم وتحديدا في الخرطوم بحري
استمر تحليق سلاح الجو السوداني خصوصا في
شنبات ورد دعم السريع باسلحه مضاده
للطائرات علما ان الاشتباكات تركزت في
اليومين الماضيين في منطقه جسر الحلفايه
وهي منطقه مكتظه بالسكان في اليوم الاخير
من الهدنه الخامسه ظل وسط الخرطوم وتحديدا
المناطق حوالي القصر الرئاسي ومقر قياده
الجيش صحه اشتباكات متقطعه وشهدت تصاعد
للدخان بينما اتهم الدعم السريع قوه الجيش
بمهاجمه موقع تمركز قوته في عدد من
المناطق بولايه الخرطوم تطورات الاسبوعين
الماضيين اظهرت ان الاستراتيجيه التي
يعتمدها الدعم السريع تتمثل في تجميع
قواته في العاصمه القوميه الخرطوم مركز
المواجهات بمدنها الثلاث بينما تتمثل
استراتيجيه الجيش في قطع خطوط امداد الدعم
السريع خصوصا من الولايات الغربيه وكان
الجيش السوداني اعلن استهدافه ارتالا
عسكريه وتدميره عربه لدعم السريع قادمه من
شمل دارفور قرب منطقه زريبه بولايه شمال
كردفان وفي منطقه المويلح وفتاشه غربي ام
درمان وتبدو نقاط تمركز لدعم السريع
لتحريك قوته نحو الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
معنى من ام درمان مراسل الجزيره حسن رزاق
ومن جنوبي الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره محمد
الطيب محمد ابدا بك لتطلعنا على الوضع
الميداني وكذلك الوضع الانساني
نعم في المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه هنا من
العاصمه الخرطوم كانت كان فيها هدوء حذر
لم نسمع في الواقع اي اشتباكات وقعت في
هذه المنطقه عموما
الملاحظ خلال هذا اليوم يوم البارحه هو
حركه المواصلات الداخليه
كانت متوقفه خلال منذ بدء الاشتباكات
ولكنها اليوم بدات تعود تدريجيا وجزئيا في
عدد من مناطق والشوارع هنا حيث رصدنا عدد
من الحافلات
الركاب والنقل
والحافلات الصغيره كانت تقل المواطنين من
مناطق مختلفه منهم من يتوجه الى منطقه
بحري مستخدما كوبري سوبا او كوبري ماجيه
ومنهم من يتحرك الى داخل الخرطوم
عموما هذه المنطقه خلال الايام الماضيه لم
تشهد اشتباكات
مباشره ما بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم لكنها كانت هاديه نوعا ما
نسمع من حين الى اخر اصوات الرصاص
والمضادات الطيران ولكنها متفرقه وليست
بالشيء الكبير تحدثنا مع عدد من المواطنين
خلال هذا اليوم وجدنا ان عددا من الذين
يعملون برزق اليوم باليوم العمال قد خرجوا
للبحث عن اعمالهم ومحاوله
الحصول على المال بحكم ان ما لديهم من
سيول نقديه ومدخروهم من مال خلال الايام
الماضيه قد نفت بالتالي هم بحاجه الى
العمل وبحاجه الى الخروج وبالحاجه الى
التنقل لجمع المال
ويعني تقديمه لعائلتهم وشراء ما يحتاجونه
من مواد غذائيه بهذا
عموما المنطقه هنا خلال الساعات الاخيره
منذ اعلان وتمديد الهدنه
الجو كان حاليا لم نسمعها في الواقع الا
الطلقات رصاص متقطعه وقليله وليست
بالكثيره وبالتالي
المواطنون في هذه المناطق بداوا
يتعايشون مع هذا الواقع وبداوا يتحركون
عدد من المتاجر فتحت ابوابها للناس الحركه
النشطه مع هذا الواقع محمد ولكن في ذات
الوقت موضوع
الاشتباكات والجانب العسكري المهدد قل
بشكل ملحوظ يمكن ان نقول في المنطقه التي
تتواجد فيها جنوب شرق الخرطوم
نعم في منطقه المتواجد فيها اخر اشتباك
كانت وقعت يوم العيد وثاني ايام العيد
وثالث ايام العيد كانت هناك اشتباكات وقعت
قبل يومين في منطقه الطائف لكنها لم تستمر
طويلا عدا ذلك نسمع مضادات الطيران عندما
تحلق طائره في الاجواء هنا يقوم قوات
الدعم السريع بالرد عليها بمضادات الطيران
عموما هذه المنطقه لم تشهد مواجهات ساخنه
كما كان عليه الحال في منطقه بحري
والحلفايه والمعونه من منطقه ام درمان لكن
الحذر من المواطنين هو السيد الموقف
وبالتالي يحاول المواطنين العيش والتعايش
مع هذا الواقع
بالحركه وبالحصول على المال النقدي
والحركه من اجل تغطيه احتياجاتهم اليوميه
شكرا جزيلا لك من جنوبي الخرطوم راس
الجزيره محمد الطيب وانتقل اليك حسن في ام
درمان كيف
يمكنك ان تصف الوضع هناك
عثمان طوال اليوم رصدنا في ام درمان جمله
من الخروقات رصدنا ايضا حصيله من
الاشتباكات المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع على الاقل اتحدث عن
جنوب ام درمان طبعا شمال ام درمان هي
منطقه سالمه وامنه وان كانت هناك بعض
التداعيات المعيشيه كشح الوقود وشح حسين
النقديه لكن تظل منطقه امنه اما عن جنوب
الخرطوم عن جنوب ام درمان وهي المنطقه
التي تشهد منذ اسبوعين اشتباكات مسلحه
سواء على الارض سواء على الجو لازلنا نشهد
خروقات لهذه الطوال اليوم كان هناك وتيره
من الاشتباكات تتصاعد حين وتقل حينا لكنها
كانت مستمره بشكل متقطع لكن الان هناك
هدوء نسبي صيام ان غالبا الاشتباكات تهدا
في الليل ما عدا بعض الاعير الناريه تنطلق
من هنا هنا على كل حال المواطنون في جنوب
ام درمان بعضهم بدا يتعايش مع الوضع
وبعدهم لا زال حذرا سيما مع حاله السيوله
الامنيه التي تشهدها هذه المناطق وانا
الغياب التام للشرطه ورجال الانف وبالتالي
خروجهم من المنازل بعد اوقات المساء باتا
بحذر وايضا عند للضروره على الذين تاقلموا
رصدنا اليوم في جوله في شوارع ام دران
عوده لبعض
الانشطه الرياضيه لسكان الحي ايضا بعض
المحال بدات تفتح محل رغم وجود نقص كبير
في المال لكن على اي حال القاسم المشترك
بين سكان اندروه التداعيات المعيشيه فقدان
السيوله النقديه
غلاء الاسعار الامور الطبيه هذه اذا
شاركون لكن مناطق الاشتباك تختلف من منطقه
لمنطقه هناك مناطق امنه وهناك مناطق على
تخوم هذه الاشتباكات هم المتضررين عثمان
رزاق شكرا جزيلا لك حسن
الداخليه السودانيه وزاره الداخليه قالت
ان المقر الرئيسه للبنك المركزي الكائن في
منطقه المجرم في العاصمه الخرطوم لم يتعرض
لاي قصف واضافت في بيان على صفحتها في
فيسبوك ان صور الحريق التي جرى تداولها
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تعود لحريق
قديم شب في احد فروع البنك المركزي على حد
تعبيرها
هذه هي الصور طبعا التي تم الحديث عنها
وهي صور بالفعل انتشرت على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ولكن كما ذكرنا وزاره الداخليه
نفت ان يكون فرع البنك قد تعرض لقصف
حسابات عبر منصات التواصل
اظهرت هذا المقطع في بنك الخرطوم فرع
السوبر من قبل مواطنين واظهرت اللقطات
المصوره مواطنين يحملون اموالا بعد سرقتها
من البنك في ظل استمرار الفلتان الامن
هذا هو اثار انتشار قوات الاحتياطيه
المركزيه الجنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم
والتساؤلات بشان موقفي باقي المؤسسات
الامنيه في السودان من طرفي الصراع ومن
القتال الدائري بينهما لا سيما بعد غياب
مؤسسات امنيه واسياديه مثل الشرطه
والمخابرات عن المشهد الداخلي رغم الحاله
الامنيه التي تعصف بالبلاد منذ منتصف
الشهر الجاري
بعد غياب كامل عن المشهد منذ اندلاع
القتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع قبل
اسبوعين تظهر في شوارع الخرطوم لاول مره
قوات الاحتياطي المركزي التابعه لوزاره
الداخليه تقول الوزاره في بيان لها انها
خرجت الى الميدان لتامين الاسواق وممتلكات
المواطنين التي تعرضت للنهب والسلب
والتخريب مؤكده ان قوات الاحتياطي المركزي
فصيل تابع للشرطه يقوده ضباط من خريجي
كليه علوم الشرطه والقانون في رد على
اتهامات الدعم السريع لها بانها تابعه لما
يعرف بكتائب الامن الشعبي في اشاره الى
انها مجموعه امنيه محسوبه على نظام الرئيس
المعزول عمر البشير تاسست قوات الاحتياطي
المركزي في عام
1974 ضمن ست وحدات اساسيه للشرطه
السودانيه يقدر عدد قوات الاحتياطي
المركزي نحو 80 الف شرطي موزعين على جميع
ولايات السودان ومؤهلين للقيام بمهام
الشرطه خصوصا في مجال فض النزاعات المحليه
القبليه تتمتع هذه القوات بتسليح اكثر
تقدما من بقيه وحدات الشرطه يشمل طائرات
عموديه فرضت الولايات المتحده العام
الماضي عقوبات على هذه القوات بعد ان
اتهمتها بارتكاب انتهاكات خطيره لحقوق
الانسان اثناء فض المظاهرات السودانيه
المطالبه بانهاء الحكم العسكري واضافه الى
طرفي الصراع وقوات الشرطه يبقى في المشهد
السوداني جهاز المخابرات العامه الذي يتبع
رئاسه الجمهوريه ويقوده الفريق اول احمد
ابراهيم
وباستثناء بيان صحفي يعلن عن قرار لمدير
الجهاز انهى بموجبهم تذاب جميع الضباط
وضباط الصف المنتدبين للعمل بقوات الدعم
السريع فانه لم يصدر عن الجهاز اي تصريحات
او تحركات
مرتبطه بالقتال الدائر في البلاد بين
الجيش والدعم السريع وكان جهاز المخابرات
العامه الذي عرف سابقا باسم جهاز
المخابرات والامن الوطني يتمتع بالسلطات
واسعه لكن دوره تراجع بشكل كبير بعد
الاطاحه بنظام البشير وتفكيك هيئه
العمليات التي كانت توصف بالذراع العسكري
الضاربي لجهاز الامن الوطني بقوه قوامها
14 الفرد وقد تم تخيير منسوبها بعد
الاحداث الامنيه التي شهدتها الخرطوم مطلع
العام 2020 اما بالانضمام للجيش او الدعم
السريع او التسريحين من الخدمه
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي السوداني ضياء الدين بلال استاذ
ضياء اهلا وسهلا بك اذا ما بدانا من حيث
كان التقرير يتحدث عن اجهزه الامن
المخابرات الشرطه هل غابت بالفعل حتى هذه
اللحظه هل يمكن ان نقول المخابراتها وكيف
نفعل المخابرات غابت هي المخابرات ثم
اضعاف خلال الفتره الانتقاليه باعتبار
انها نزعت منها كثير من الصلاحيات واصبحت
خاصه فقط بجمع المعلومات وتقديم المعلومات
والمشوره للجهاز التنفيذي فبالتالي لم تعد
بذات القوه التي كانت عليها في النظام
السابق حينما كانت تملك وحده خاصه
بالعمليات بها اكثر من 13 من من 13 الف
مقاتل ولكن تم حل هذه الوحده في اعتقادك
لا اعتقد انه كان خطا لانه تم تسييس هذه
الوحده هي وحده مهنيه لحد كبير جدا لانها
كانت مهيا للتعامل مع مثل هذه السيناريوه
السيناريوهات كانت مهيئه للتعامل مع حرب
المدن مع حرب العصابات وكانت معده لهذا
يبدو ان هذا السيناريو كان متوقع في
ذهنيه متخذ القرار في ذلك الوقت بانه يمكن
ان تاتي لحظه ان تصبح الخرطوم تحت سيطره
حركه مسلحه في ذلك الوقت لم يكن الظنون
تمضي اتجاه الدعم السريع باعتباره الحليف
الاساسي ولكن كانت توقع يمضي اتجاه
الحركات المسلحه وكانت هنالك عمليه شهيره
تدعى عمليه الزراعه الطويله التي قام بها
قامت بها حركه العدل والمساواه فحل هذه
الوحده اعتقد انه اضعف بشكل كبير جدا جهاز
الشرطه عادت جزئيا ما اهميه هذا المتغير
هي الشرطه عادت في الاماكن الامنه المسيطر
عليها من قبل الجيش لان السلطه غير مهيئه
للتعامل كمان كذلك مع مع اسلحه وعربات
وسيارات الدعم السريع فهي عادت في الاماكن
امنه لحد ما
لتوفر الامن
الدعم السريع يواجهها اصلا اذا كان دورها
سوف يقتصر على حمايه الممتلكات وتامين هذه
المباني يفترض ان الدعم السريع لم يواجهها
لا الدعم
بعد ان الفشل في الوصول الى الغايات التي
حدثتها وهي الغاء القبض على البرهان
وتقديمه الى المحاكمه والانتقال الى
العمليه السياسيه يبدو انه الان يسعى في
سيناريو اخر من شقين رفع التكلفه
الانسانيه والسياسيه للحرب وكذلك اعاقه
عمل الدوله حتى تكون هذه الاوراق الضغطه
حينما ياتي التفاوض يكون لديه اوراق
هناك تقدم كبير تعتبر على اعتبار انه تم
تسميه شخصين العميد موسى عثمان من الدعم
السريع ولواء الركن ابو بكر الفقيري من
القوات المسلحه تقدم شكلي لا اعتقد انه
تقدم حقيقي متداعيات ومجريات الاحداث على
الواقع الميداني هي المتحكمه الاساسي ولكن
كل طرف يريد ان لا يظهر امام المجتمع
الدولي بانه غير راغب في ايقاف الحرب
لاسباب انسانيه وغير راقب على الالتزام
بالهنه فهو يبدي هذه يبدي يبدي هذه الاراء
عبر الاقوال ولكن الافعال تمضي في
يفترض ان يكون الطرف المنتصر فقط هو الذي
لا يريد الهدنه الطرف
المهزوم على افتراض يجب ان يريد ليلتقط ان
يستريح ليتجنب الهزيمه نعم ليست هنالك
الان ليس هنالك انتصار حاسم لا تزال هنالك
معادلات صحيحه الجيش يده العليا في
العمليات العسكريه الكبرى ولكن الدعم
السريع منتشر موجود في مناطق كثيره ومسيطر
على على مقر استراتيجيه مثل قصر الجمهوري
ويهدد المطار ويهدد القياده العامه
فبالتالي هو خطر ماثل الدعم السريع والجيش
يتقدم بطريقته الجيش بطبيعته بطيء في
تحركاته
في عمليات عسكريه بالاسلحه الثقيله تترتب
عليها خساره سياسيه داخليا بان ينفض هذه
تنفض هذه الحاله من حالات الالتفاف الوطني
النادره جدا حول الجيش لانه اذا تكاثرت
الماسي
سيكون هنالك حاجز نفسي كبير وما بين الجيش
والمواطن العادي كذلك استعداء
الاطراف الدوليه وهي مؤثره والمنظمات شكرا
جزيلا ضياء الدين بلال الكاتبه المحلل
السياسي السوداني شكرا جزيلا في العرض
التالي نتابع معكم كيف بدا المشهد في
السودان او كيف بدا في الساعات الماضيه
[موسيقى]
في المساعي الاقليميه والدوليه دعت الاليه
الثلاثيه المسهله للحوار في السودان كلا
من البرهان وحمايه الى تمديد اخر لوقف
اطلاق النار مدته 72 ساعه واضافت الاليه
في بيان ان وقف اطلاق النار يمهد الطريق
لاجراء محادثات بين الجانبين من اجل تحديد
وقف دائم للاعمال القتاليه من جانبه دعا
وزير خارجيه جيبوتي محمود علي يوسف طرفي
الصراع في السودان الى فتح قنوات التواصل
لتجنيب البلاد الانهيار على حد قوله كما
اعرب عن قلق بلاده من اتساع رقعه
المواجهات وفشل الهدن في السودان وقال ان
سقوط الدوله هناك ستكون له عواقب وخيمه
على القاره الافريقيه كلها
هدن تلوى هدى كثيرا ما تمدد ونادرا ما
تحترم اما تبادل الاتهامات بخرقها فقد
كرسها المتناحرون في السودان قاعده
حتى الان لا يبدي اي من طرفي الازمه هناك
حماسا للجلوس الى طاوله الحوار تضع الجهود
الاقليميه والدوليه ذلك في الحسبان وهي
تبحث عن وقف القتال المستمر منذ ثلاثه
اسابيع صحيح ان الوساطات الاخره في
التبلور ان بشكل فردي او ثنائي او جماعي
تدعو جميعها طرفي الصراع لفتح قنوات
للتواصل لكنها عمليا تركز في الوقت الراهن
على مسعى تثبيت وقف اطلاق النار وادامته
وبينما تنشط دبلوماسيه السلام على صعد
مختلفه بدا ان جوار السودان هو اكثر من
يستشعر الخطر
السودان بلد كبير هو تقريبا يعتبر القلب
النابض للقاره الافريقيه وله حدود مع
ثمانيه دول
اي انتكاسه اي يعني انهيار للدوله في
السودان
سيكون له انعكاسات خطيره للقاره باكملها
الهياكل الرسميه للقاره قد تملك في راي
الداعين لافرقت الازمه بعض مفاتيح الحل ان
لم تكن كلها لكن الافارقه ليسوا وحدهم كما
يبدو على ساحه الوساطات القائم منها
والمحتمل
فمن بوسعه حقا فرض وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
واجبار الطرفين على الحوار
تمارس اكبر الضغوط حاليا كما يعتقد على
الجيش والدعم السريع من قبل الاليه
الثلاثيه بشان السودان تلك التي تضم كلا
من البعثه الامميه والاتحاد الافريقي
والهيئه الحكوميه للتنميه في الشرقي
افريقيا ايجاد
تفعل الشيء ذاته على الاغلب اللجنه
الرباعيه
وتتشكل هذه اللجنه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبريطانيا وكلاهما يحث
السودانيين على التهدئه واستعاده المسار
الديمقراطي الى جانب العضوين العربيين
الامارات والسعوديه هنا في المملكه يستقبل
وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان المبعوث الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي السوداني السفير دفع الله الحاج
علي الوزير السعودي اكد على دعوه المملكه
للتهدئه وتغذيب المصلحه الوطنيه ووقف كل
اشكال التصعيد العسكري في السودان
لا يعرف بعد ما فرص تحقيق ذلك لكنه هو
عينه ما تنشده الامم المتحده بدا لرئيس
بعثتها في السودان ان طرفي النزاع بتاء
اكثر انفتاحا الان على المفاوضات ليس هناك
مفاوضات مباشره لكن
حريص على ان لا يقول الان اكثر من ذلك
اعلنت الامم المتحده ان امينها العام قرر
ارسال منسق الشؤون الانسانيه مارتن جرافيث
فورا الى المنطقه في ضوء الازمه المتدهوره
في السودان وجاء في بيان للمتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده ان حجم وتسارع
وتيره الاحداث غير مسبوق واعرب عن قلق
المنظمه من التاثير الفوري والطويل الامد
على السودان والمنطقه وحث البيان اطراف
النزاع على حمايه المدنيين والبنيه
التحتيه المدنيه والسماح بمرور المدنيين
الفارين من مناطق القتال واحترام العاملين
في المجال الانساني والطبي
تنضم الينا من هراري عاصمه زيمبابوي
الاتحاد الافريقي السابقه لدى واشنطن
الدكتوره اريكاننا اهلا وسهلا بك دكتوره
هناك عمل للاليه ثلاثيه الاتحاد الافريقي
ايجاد وايضا الامم المتحده وهناك الرباعيه
نتحدث عن الامارات والسعوديه والمملكه
المتحده والولايات المتحده
ايهما الاكثر تاثيرا في رايك في هذا
الصراع ولماذا
[موسيقى]
حل كل ازمه في القاره الافريقيه ينبغي ان
يكون طبعا في ايادي الافارقه اعتقد انه من
مسؤوليه الاتحاد الافريقيه ان يطلع بحل
الازمات في افريقيا طبعا بقيه الاطراف
مرحب بها لكن على الافارقه ان يحلوا
مشاكلهم بايديهم عليهم ان يفعل ذلك ربما
يشعرون بالواجب لان يبدو ذلك ولكن هل هم
قادرون على فعل ذلك وماذا بيدهم من اوراق
دعوني اقول ان الاتحاد الافريقيه توفر على
مجموعه من الادوات بدايه طبعا
لجنه الامن والسلام التابعه للاتحاد
الافريقي ولديهم ايضا
ادوات اخرى منظمات
منظمه الدفاع الافريقي لدينا ايضا
الايجاد
وهذه المنظمه تتطلع بحفظ الامن والسلام
وهناك ايضا الصندوق للامن والسلام
الافريقي هناك ايضا لجنه او مجلس الحكماء
يبقى دائما جاهز للتدخل في اي لحظه وايضا
هناك مجموعه من الادوات
في يد الاتحاد الافريقي لحل الازمات
والخلافات في افريقيا لكن التحدي الكبير
الذي يواجه
الاتحاد الافريقي وتدخل من الخارج معظم
الازمات في افريقيا هي مفتعله من قبل
الخارج كما تعلمون
بالنسبه للاتحاد الافريقي فهو يتوفر على
كل الوسائل والادوات لكن التحدي الاكبر
الذي يواجه فارقه هو التدخل من الخارج قد
يكون هذا التدخل مفيدا احيانا الان يعني
الهدنه هي بواسطه سعوديه امريكيه واريد ان
اسالك عن الدوري الامريكي تحديدا باعتبار
انك كنت سفيره الاتحاد الافريقي الافريقي
في واشنطن كيف تعتقدين ان واشنطن في هذا
الصراع في السودان يمكن ان تتدخل ويمكن ان
تضغط لتغيير الامور
اما نعم
اسالك باعتبارك كنت سفيره الاتحاد
الافريقي في واشنطن كيف تعتقدين ان واشنطن
ستتدخل وكيف ستضغط على طرفين
نعم في الواقع اعتقد ان واشنطن
المتحده اطراف لعبه دور جيد في الازمه ما
بين السودان وجنوب السودان ونحن
نقدر هذا الدور ونتمنى ان يطلع ايضا بنفس
الدوره الفاعل اي دور من قبل المتحده
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك اخرى
تحاول ان تلعب دورا ايجابيا في هذا الخصوص
لكن على هذه الاطراف ان تعي جيدا بان
عليها ان تفكر اولا وقبل كل شيء بالشعب
السوداني وهذا هو الذي يجب ان يقود اي
وساطه على الفريق ايضا ان يكون واعون
بالمسؤوليه الملقاه على عاتقهم لقياده
شعوب افريقيا واعتقد ان الاطراف الخارجيه
قد تكون ايجابيه
وقد تشكل ايضا تحديا في نفس الوقت لكن على
فريقه ان ياخذوا بزمام الامور ويجب على
القاده الافارقه ان يكونوا فعلا قاد
لشعبهم عاصمه زيمبابوي سفيره الاتحاد
الافريقي السابقه في واشنطن الدكتور
اريكانا شامبوري شكرا جزيلا لك
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تشهد ازمه حاده
في الوقود لا سيما في جنوب المدينه حيث
توقفت بعض محطات الوقود عن العمل بسبب
تدهور الاوضاع الامنيه وتوقف الامدادات
البتروليه واصطفى الطوابير طويله من
سيارات المواطنين امام المحطات التي لا
تزال تعمل
هذا
وحذر برنامج الاغذيه العالمي من ان العنف
الدائره في السودان يمكن ان يسبب ازمه
انسانيه في منطقه شرق افريقيا كلها وقال
مدير المنظمه في المانيا مارتن فريك ان
هناك نقصا في كل شيء كما ارتفعت اسعار
الغذاء بصوره كبيره مشيرا الى ان الثلث
سكان السودان كانوا يعانون من الجوع
بالفعل قبل اندلاع الاشتباكات واضاف ان
الاسعار ارتفعت في جنوب السودان بما يصل
الى 28% خلال فتره قصيره وان زيادات
مماثله في الاسعار سجلت في تشاد واضاف
فريك ان ارتفاع الضغط على امدادات الاغذيه
بسبب مواسم الامطار السيئه يزيد الازمه
سوءا في منطقه القرن الافريقي
في هذه الاثناء قالت الناطقه الرسميه
للصليب الاحمر اليمنى سينينكو للجزيره ان
طائره تابعه للمنظمه هبطت في مطار
بورسودان وعلى متنها ثمانيه اطنان من
المواد الطبيه وانطلقت شحنه من المواد
الطبيه المنقذه للحياه اليوم الاحد من
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان الى بورسودان ضمن
عمليات الطوارئ التي تنفذها اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر عقب اندلاع النزاع
في السودان
وتضم الشحنه معدات جراحيه لدعم مستشفيات
السودان ومتطوعي جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
السوداني الذين يقدمون الرعايه الطبيه
لجرحى المواجهات المسلحه
هذا واعلنت القنصليه الروسيه في جده في
السعوديه ان المملكه اجلت عددا من
المواطنين الروس من السودان الى جده على
متن سفينه عسكريه وكانت الخارجيه السعوديه
قالت في بيان انها اجلت من السودان خمسه
الاف ومئه وسبعه وتسعين شخصا من مئه دوله
منذ بدات عمليات الاجلاء
وقد وصلت اليوم الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه السفينه الدرعيه وعلى متنها 52 من
رعايه دول عده في الرحله الثالثه عشره
للاسطول البحري الجوي
ووصلت صباح اليوم الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
سفينه اجلاء هنديه قادمه من السودان وعلى
متنها
288 شخصا
كما وصل مواطنون سعوديون وباكستانيون على
متن طائره تابعه للقوات الجويه الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه في جده
قال مسؤولان امريكيان ان الولايات المتحده
ارسلت سفينه تابعه للبحريه الى السودان
للمساعده في اجراء المواطنين الامريكيين
الذين تقطعت بهم السبل بعد اندلاع القتال
وقال المسؤولان اللذان تحدثا شريطه عدم
الكشف عن هويتهما ان السفينه يو اس اس ان
وهي سفينه نقل سريع توجد في بورسودان بصفه
مؤقته
واضاف احدهما انه من المرجح اجلاء مئات
المواطنين الامريكيين على متن هذه السفينه
قالت الخارجيه البريطانيه انه تم اجلاء
اكثر من 2000 ومئه شخص من السودان في اكبر
واطول اجلاء لاي بلد غربي
واضافت الخارجيه البريطانيه في تغريدان
المملكه المتحده ستسير رحله اجلاء اضافيه
من بورسودان غدا الاثنين
اعلنت الخارجيه الايرانيه عوده جميع
المواطنين الايرانيين الذين كانوا يقيمون
في السودان الى البلاد واشاره الخارجيه
الى اجراء خمسه وستين مواطنا ايرانيا من
الخرطوم خلال الايام الماضيه حيث نقلوا
الى ميناء جده السعودي ومنه الى العاصمه
الايرانيه طهران
اللاجئون السودانيون يواجهون وهم الذين
الذين وصلوا بتحديد الى تشاد بعد اندلاع
الحرب في بلادهم يواجهون صعوبات في الحصول
على ضروريات الحياه واكد برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه حاجته الى نحو 142 مليون دولار
لتمويل برامجها الخاصه بتوفير الغذاء
للاجئين
رصد اوضاع اللاجئين في قريه
كفرن على الحدود مع السودان
كفرا شرقيه على بعد مئات الامتار فقط من
الاراضي السودانيه اكثر من عشره الاف لاجئ
سوداني وصلوا الى الجانب الكادي من الحدود
الظروف التي وجدوها توفر مامنا من الحرب
وحسب
السيده زمزم تركت بلدتها تندلتي في ولايه
غرب دارفور التي طالها القتال بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع وفي هذا المكان وفي
غياب اي رعايه طبيه وضعت زمزم مولودها
الاول بعد ايام على هروبها من الحرب
من وليد ترى
المساعده الطبيه نوعا من الكماليات
فالاف اللاجئين السودانيين ومعظمهم من
الاطفال والنساء يواجهون ظروف حياه يصعب
معها الحصول على الغذاء والدواء والماوى
هنا
لدينا نقص حاد في التمويل تحدثنا بشكل
صريح منذ نهايه السنه الاخيره عن حاجياتنا
وبينا ذلك قبل اسابيع ايضا نحن بحاجه
لمائه 142 مليون دولار لاعانه 600 الف
لاجئ مسجلين في برنامج الغذاء العالمي
والان مع هذه الازمه الجديده في السودان
فان هذا يعني مزيدا من اللاجئين
السودانيين تشتد درجات الحراره نهارا في
هذه المنطقه خلال هذه الفتره
وتتجاوز احيانا اربعين درجه مئويه لا
يختارها اولاء اللاجئون مثل هذه الاماكن
التي لا تقيهم حر الشمس نهارا ولا البرد
ليلا لكنها تقيهم على الاقل من الرصاص
الطائش وغير الطائش في ديار الحرب
بالسودان
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره كفرا منطقه ادريس
على الحدود التجاديه السودانيه
ايضا
وسط محاولات لانقاذه قبل ساعات من افتتاح
البورصات بنك
الامريكي يواجه شبح الانهيار خلال اقل من
شهر
[موسيقى]
بدرجات متفاوته يستمر القتال في شتى مناطق
الشرق الاوكراني لكن جبهه الحرب الرئيسيه
تظل باخموت الواقعه تحت النار منذ نحو
ثمانيه اشهر وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت
في بيان السيطره على مناطق اخرى في
المدينه
قواتنا تواصل هجماتها على محور دونيتسك
وفي الجانب الغربي من مدينه باخموت سيطرت
قواتنا على اربعه احياء كما تمكنت الوحدات
الهجوميه بدعم من القوات المحموله جوا من
دفع القوات الاوكرانيه الى الجزء الغربي
من مدينه ضخمه وقد نشرت ميليشيا فاجنر
التي تقود الهجوم مقاطع فيديو اظهرت
انتشار قناصتها داخل مباني شاهقه خلال
المعارك الدائره هناك
لكن ما يبدو تفوقا روسيا في بخموت حتى
الان تربكه تصريحات جديده لقائد المجموعه
لوح فيها بسحب بعض قواته من الجبهه اذا لم
تنهي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مشكله نقص
الذخيره وتلك مصاعب يفاقمها اكثر تصميم
القوات الاوكرانيه على التصدي للهجوم
الروسي وشنها هجمات مضاده كهذه التي
يظهرها فيديو نشره الجيش الاوكراني مؤكدا
ان مقاتليه استعادوا السيطره على محور في
بخموت كانت تسيطر عليه القوات الروسيه بعد
ان تمكنوا من قتل عدد من جنودها واسرع
اخرين
تلك المستجدات الميدانيه وغيرها دفعت
القياده السياسيه في اوكرانيا الى الذهاب
بعيدا في اتخاذ مزيد من القرارات
الاستراتيجيه
سيفيني
بصراحه الدعم الغربي سيساعدنا كثيرا لكننا
نتفهم ايضا انه لا يمكننا ربط الهجوم
المضاد بالخارج ولهذا السبب سنبدا الهجوم
المضاده قبل تسلم طائرات اف 16 او طرازات
اخرى لن نسمح لروسيا بالاستفاده من حقيقه
حاجتنا الى شهرين للتدريب على الطائره لا
لن يحدث هذا سنبدا ونمضي قدما
الهجوم الاوكراني المزمع لم يمنع زيلينسكي
من التذكير بمقترحه للسلام المكون من عشر
نقاط لانهاء الحرب وهو ما ناقشه هاتفيا
الاحد مع نظيره الفرنسي
بالنسبه للمتحدثه باسم القياده الجنوبيه
في الجيش الاوكراني فان استعداد كيف
لهجومها المضاد في شرق البلاد بدا السبت
بقصف طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه منشاه لتخزين
النفط في مدينه سيفا ستوبول التابعه لشبه
جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا عام 2014
والهجوم المرتقب جاءت مؤشراته ايضا من
موسكو التي اعلنت تعيين الجنرال
نائبا لوزير الدفاع الروسي مكلفا
بالامدادات الماديه والتقنيه للقوات
المسلحه بدلا من الجنرال ميخائيل
ميزنتيزيف الذي قاد الحصار الطويل على
مدينه ماريو بولو الساحليه في جنوب شرق
اوكرانيا
ينضم الينا من نيويورك العقيد مايلز كبير
الباحثين في معهد نيو لاينز للاستراتيجيه
والسياسه ويندرويد
والاستراتيجي سيد فرولو هل القوات
المواليه للروسيا في مازق كبير رغم تقدمها
في بخموت
لا اعتقد انهم في مازق لان حسب المعلومات
الاستخبارات فيها فان الوضع فيه
صعب جدا بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه
الروسيه اعتقد ان
الامور تتجه نحو الحسم بالنسبه للروس وهذا
حسب تقديري العقيد مايلز اذن لا يجب
المبالغه في نقص الذخيره والاشياء التي
يتحدث عنها رئيس باجنر في النهايه القوات
المواليه لروسيا متقدمه ومسيطره الى حد
كبير
نحن في هذه الحرب لازيد من عام هناك طبعا
قلق
بخصوص
امدادات الذخيره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تستثمر المزيد من الاموال من
اجل توفير ما يكفي من الداخره بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا وايضا بالنسبه لاعاده تزويد
مخازن وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اعتقد ان
هناك مشكل كبير على مستوى داخل بالنسبه
المتحده الامريكيه فهي تزود اوكرانيا
بافضل المعدات من اجل هزم القوات الروسيه
يجب عدم التقليل ايضا من مما تعنيه هذه
القوات لان رئيس فاجنر نفسه هدد وصل الامر
لدرجه انه هدد بسحب بعض جنوده اذا لم تحل
مشكله الذخيره هذه يبدو انه يعني قوته
تعاني منه من هذه المشكله بقوه
عندما نتحدث عن الوضع بخصوص الذخيره
والامدادات علينا
نتحدث عن قوه
الروس من جهه اخرى لان سلاسل الامداد
بالنسبه للطرفين تختلف بشكل كامل ولا
اعتقد
ان هناك
نقص على مستوى ذخيره بشكل عام بالنسبه
للروس وهذا لا يؤثر على اداء الروس في
المرحله الراهن نعتقد ان السيد بريكولجن
يحاول فقط ان يقود نوع من
نوع من الدعايه ولكن الوضع ليس كما يحاول
ان يثوره ولكن بشكل عام الروس لديهم ما
يكفي من
الذخيره في اوكرانيا لاستمرار في هذه
الحرب وهنا كما يكفي ايضا من المعدات
العسكريه هناك ما يكفي اذا العقيد مايلز
ام ان الاوكرانيين وحلفائهم الغربيين
استطاع وا ان يقطعوا الامدادات بشكل فعال
على الروس والقوه المواليه له المتمثله
فيفا
من اجل ان تكون اوكرانيا ناجحه في فتره
الربيع عليهم بالتاكيد قطع خطوط الامدادات
والخطوط اللوجستيه للروس ونحن نرى بان
اوكرانيا الان تقوم باستخدام
المدفعيه وايضا تعتمد على عمليه خاصه من
اجل تفكيك
القوات الروسيه والتفكيك شبكاتها
اللوجستيه من خلال السيطره على طرق
الامداد ما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه في الهجوم
المضاد الذي يتحدث عنه الرئيس زلينس كعقيد
نايلز
يمكننا ان نتوقع بان اوكرانيا ستقوم بهجوم
متعدده من اجل اضعاف القوه الروسيه من
اجل دفع ايضا خلف خطوطها ايضا اوكرانيا
تحاول ان تطهر الكثير من حقول
الغامه التي وضعتها روسيا خلال العام
الماضي واوكرانيا ستتمكن من الدفاع على
مواقعها واستعاده بعض المواقع التي
احتلتها روسيا حتى في عام
2014 نعم اوكرانيا باتت الان تتوفر على
معدات عسكريه متقدمه تتوفر على ايضا
صواريخ بعيده المدى والمعنويات في صفوف
الوكانيين الان في سوق الجيش والقوات
الاوكرانيه عاليه جدا والعكس تماما في
صفوف القوات الروسيه العكس تماما في صفوف
القوات الروسيه سيد رولوف اعتقد انك ربما
تعترض على هذا ولكن هذا ما يقال من فتره
طويله ان المعنويات لدى الجنود الروس ليس
عاليه
انا وزميلي من واشنطن نتحدث عن حربين
مختلفتين روما حسب البيانات المتوفره
لدينا في روسيا في الوضع يختلف ثمنه على
عكس ما يصفه زميلي من
واشنطن حسب الكثير من القاده العسكريين
الروس حسب توفر لدينا من بيانات ليس فقط
ما هو متوفر في روسيا ولكن ايضا في
اوكرانيا وفي مره اخرى هناك ضعف في
معنويات الجنود والجيش الاوكراني واعتقد
ان الجيش الروسي لديه اليد العليا الان في
اوكرانيا ولديه ما يكفي من الامداد من
المعدات العسكريه من اجل الاستمرار في هذه
الحرب
وطرف الاوكرانيس يحاول طبعا ان يقوم
بهجوم مضاد محدود لاختطاف
النصر صغير وتصويره على انه النصر الكبير
العقيد مايلز الرئيس يقول انه سيبدا
الهجوم المضاد حتى قبل ان يتم التدريب على
طائرات اف 16 التي سوف يستلمها من الناحيه
العسكريه هل تعتقد انه من الحكمه ان يفعل
ذلك
وقواته في هذا الهجوم المضاد الذي قد يبدا
في اي لحظه وحين
واعتقد ان الجيش الاوكراني الان يحضر
القيام هجوم ومضاد عبر عده محاور ولديهم
مجموعه من الامتيازات هم يعرفون الخطه
مسبقه ويقومون بتجهيز ما يكفي من القوات
من اجل استعاده مجموعه من المدن الروز
طبعا
لديهم الكثير من القوات موجوده في شرق
اوكرانيا على خصوص وينبغي لهم الدفاع على
هذه القوات لان لديهم القوات المتفرقه في
مناطق الجغرافيه الشاسعه في اوكرانيا شكرا
جزيلا من نيويورك العقيد مايلز كبير
الباحثين في معهد نيولز للاستراتيجيه
والسياسه ومن موسكو اندريه
والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لكم
[موسيقى]
تسع سلطات التنظيميه الى عثور على مشترن
لبنك فيرست الامريكيه المتعثر في محاوله
منها لانقاذ البنك قبيل افتتاح البورصات
غدا الاثنين وقالت مصادر ان بنوك عده قدمت
عروضها بناء على طلب هيئه تامين الودائع
الفيدراليه وانه من المتوقع ان يعلن
التوصل الى اتفاق الليله
واصبح بنك ثالثه بنك امريكي يواجهه
الانهيار خلال اقل من شهرين بعد ازمه
مماثله ادت الى انهيار بنكي
نتيجه سحب المودعين اموالهم وقد سحب
مودعوا بنك فارس ريبابليك 100 مليار دولار
من اموالهم في الربع الاول من هذا العام
ينضم الينا من النيه
اهلا وسهلا بك هل هذا اشبه بكره الثلج
التي سوف
تطالب البنك
تلو الاخر وستكبر هذه الكره وتسبب في
انهيارات عديده ام ان هذا شيء مؤقت هل
يمكنك ان تشرح لنا ما يحدث
الواقع هنا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هناك نقاش كبير ما بين اولئك الذين
يعتقدون بان الامر يتعلق فعلا بكره ثلج او
انهيار تلو الاخر لكن لم يكن احد يتوقع
انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي قبل سابيع
وبانك سيغنيتشر ايضا
والان الانهيار
الوشيك لبنك من الواضح بالنسبه لنا الان
باننا نواجه صعوبات ماليه كبيره السؤال
الوحيد الذي يطرح في المرحله الراهنه
كم من الوقت
يستمر لرؤيه مصاريف وابناك اخرى او بنوك
اخرى تنهار وما هي تداعيات هذه الازمه
الماليه الجديده هل هناك ما يمكن فعله
لتجنب ذلك
ما يحدث الان هو تدخل كبير من قبل الحكومه
الامريكيه
الفيدراليه وهي تحاول احتواء هذه الازمه
الماليه
وهذه الازمه تكلف ملايير الدولارات
وسيكون هناك المزيد من المشاكل
رغم امكانيه انقاذ مصرف
الان هناك عشرات المليارات من الدولارات
ونحن الان مازلنا للتو في بدايه هذه
الازمه لذلك
نتوقع ان هناك المزيد من المصاريف التي
ستنهار او ستعاني ما هو السبب هل يختصر
الامر على ان على هلع لدى المذيعين الذين
يسحبون اموالهم بشكل كبير في فتره
ام هناك اسباب اخرى يعني ما هو الفيروس
الذي يؤدي الى كل هذا في هذه البنوك
الكبيره
السبب
الرئيسي يعود لقرار
لمجموعه من اصحاب رؤوس الاموال والشركات
الناشئه في السيليكون التي سحبت اموالها
لانها كانت قلقه بان البنك ينهار الان
نرى بعد انهيار السويس
ان الامر والمشكل اعمق مما كنا نتصور واذا
سمحتم لي المشكله الان في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هو اننا بدانا نرى
بوضوح ان معارضه الولايات المتحده او موقع
المتحده الامريكيه في
الساحه الماليه الدوليه بدا يتراجع
والجميع بدا الان بدا يفكر كيف يمكنه
حمايه نفسه من انهيار الوضع الاقتصادي
والم الي في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كل بداء يتطلع الى دول اخرى كالصين ودول
اخرى صاعده في المجال المالي اذا
انهيار المصاريف والبنوك في امريكا جزء من
هذه الازمه من
الاقتصاد في جامعه ماسه
شكرا جزيلا لك
افادت دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه في القدس
ان عشرات المستوطنين المتطرفين اقتحموا
صباح اليوم الاحد المسجد الاقصى المبارك
من باب المغاربه بحمايه مشدده من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه
وتقدم المتطرف الاسرائيلي هدى كليك الجمعه
المتطرفين الذين قاموا بجولات استفزازيه
في باحات المسجد كما ادوا طقوسا تلمديه في
المنطقه الشرقيه منه وفق وكاله الصحافه
الفلسطينيه واصلت شرطه الاحتلال فرض
قيودها على دخول الفلسطينيين للمسجد
الاقصى واشارت الوكاله الى انطلاق دعوات
لتكثيف الرباط وشد الرحال الى المسجد
لافشال ما وصفتها بمخططات الاحتلال ضده
رفضت المحكمه الاسرائيليه العسكريه في سجن
عوفر اليوم الافراج عن الاسير خضره عدنان
المضرب عن الطعام منذ 85 يوما رفضا
لاعتقاله وقال نادي الاسير انه تقرر تعيين
جلسه جديده في العاشر من الشهر المقبل
للنظر في قضيه الاسير عدنان الذي كان
حاضرا عبر تقنيه الفيديو وحذر نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني من ان الاسير عدنان البالغ من
العمر 44 عاما وصل الى مرحله صحيه خطيره
يشار الى ان الاسير خضر عدنان من سكان
بلده عرابه في جنين وتعرض للاعتقال اكثر
من 12 مره بسبب عضويته ونشاطه في صفوف
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي في الضفه الغربيه
وقد حذرت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي من استمرار
تعنت السلطات الاحتلال في رفض الافراج عن
الاسير خضر عدنان المضربه عن الطعام لليوم
الخامس والثمانين على التوالي ونظمت
الحركه وقفه تضامنيه مع الاسير امام مقر
لجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في غزه
للمطالبه بتدخل المنظمات الدوليه
والانسانيه بشكل عاجل لانقاذ حياته بعد
تردي حالته الصحيه
وحملت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي سلطات
الاحتلال المسؤوليه الكامله عن حياه خضر
عدنان نتيجه استمرار اضرابه عن
[موسيقى]
الطاعه في هذه المعركه
وسيكون اليوم باذن الله عز وجل
مددت محكمه عوفر العسكريه الاسرائيليه
اعتقال النائب في البرلمان الاردني عماد
العدوان ثمانيه ايام على ذمه التحقيق جاء
ذلك في ختام جلسه سريه للمحكمه للنظر في
طلب النيابه العسكريه وجهاز الشابات
الاسرائيليين تمديد اعتقال النائب الاردني
لاستكمال التحقيق معه بتهمه محاوله تهريب
اسلحه وسبائك ذهب الى الضفه الغربيه وقال
فريق الدفاع عن النائب عماد العدوان انهم
منعوا من لقائه وكانت السلطاته
الاسرائيليه قد اعتقلت العدوان الاسبوع
الماضي لدى محاولته عبور جسر الملك حسين
وفرضت حضرا مشددا على نشر المعلومات بشان
مجريات التحقيق معه
قال وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيليه تمار
بن جافير ان تسهيل الحصول على ترخيص
للاسلحه الناريه هو احد الاهداف الشامله
لوزارته واكد من جفير انه اصدر بالفعل 12
الف ترخيص لحمل السلاح لاسرائيليين كانت
عالقه بسبب ما وصفها بالتعقيدات
البيروقراطيه